welcome to this video this is the third
and final part of my adventures I know
hinders GM in this GM tournament in
majorca the good the bad and the ugly
part free which means the ugly part yeah
those games are nothing to be proud of
but I'm going to show them anyway um and
well mostly because it was pretty
instructive how I lost so it's not very
surprising that this is a two losses so
let's that start deform this game was
played I've got black yeah it was played
against Norman uma this is the number
two ranked player in the United Arab
Emirates the you a e yeah UAE I can have
problems with that um and um he's an IM
rated 2 340 only 2 340 I had a look at
his games is actually playing better but
ok we're going to see if he also scored
a GM norm in this event so he's some
improving player he also has a good
coach and so on so very decent play and
and you before the game that it wouldn't
be easy however I made a very strange
decision on with one I played I played
this opening Canada's Sam Bishop before
check it is related to them boo goo
Indian obviously but um not quite the
same I actually decided to play that
over the board I am had another idea in
preparation but for some reason when I
was sitting there I thought why why not
go for this yeah it's kind of stuff that
you know a little bit yeah the book was
something that I know but it also may be
a slight surprise for him yeah anyway we
got to a position that I didn't like
very much but ultimately was okay for me
we would see you played 92 and I went c5
um yeah a 3 now captures Queen takes
yeah Black has given up the bishop pair
but in compensation for it the white
queen s is awkward position on d2 and
we'll move again we would see that if if
Y takes with the night I will have d5
possibly five coming up and this gives
black pretty decent chances are to
equalize to be honest I don't know this
opening very well and was pretty much
making it up over the board the only
things that I know are pretty
superficial from what a friend plays
yeah Queen takes Knight c6 Queen edge
for this looks a very normal at least it
looked normal to me and I went d5 yeah
every don't want to look at the opening
in that detail i really don't know it
that well it was as mentioned and
something i decided over the board to
play and i wasn't very happy with it but
yeah sometimes you play things that are
not really well thought out and this
opening was one of those ideas however
the loss in this game that ultimately
happens it's not blamed on the opening
really um went be4 yeah and now on it it
starts a little bit let's say um here i
can claim it seems mighty form and move
that data is so on but i mean it looked
very that looked very unambitious to me
this kind of position however it is not
that bad actually and this is due to the
fact that white has played the move b
form sometimes black can get some
counter play based on those slightly
weakened queenside them squares so let's
say I want to illustrate let's say why
takes i click with the rookin this is
going back no this kind of thing and
then let's say in a position like that
and i play with their maybe not f6
immediately but ok let's start let's
start with this this in this kind of
situation sometimes I have that is a raw
arrow hey I have this kind of square the
square 95 and so on there are some some
counter play ideas that that black hairs
or maybe I can also start thank you
something like this with with e 5 bishop
e6 and then possibly i can use the
square I'm not saying blank is great but
this is a playable position which is
just a bit better for white um okay I
went a five instead attacking this
immediately my idea was I am a little
bit better developed obviously I'm
already castled and he has not moved the
bishop and cattle so I wanted to gain
those those kind of squares yeah and get
another tempo on the queen however it
seems that this simple 94 was a bit
better after Bishop b2 I went night g6
better it's night f5 something that I
did not really appreciate that much
after night f5 Queen f4 and then
possibly a form i have this counter play
idea which gives black a decent position
I didn't want to go to f5 because it
looked strange to me it just sits in
this g4 idea but it was an interesting
way to try for counter play I went 96
and the the thing is that after night g6
he now um has a strong move that gives
white the better game um a simple move
actually just queen deform I mean I saw
that of course not very difficult to see
24 but sheer white is why this better
somewhat am I can i can take let's say
here then develop and I'll be six or
something with Bishop e7 white has the
bishop pair and is slightly better
with a comfortable position really i
originally I thought that maybe I have
rupee eight this is an interesting way
to play the ideas to push fif but white
can even play that one neglecting its
development even further but it is just
wrong it is just wrong due to this
pressure here I have a hard time too
sorry hey I have a hard time to to get
ever this gets bishop I whatever right
this is I cannot move those pawns I
cannot move the night I have to do
something like this and this is a yeah
this is not very very much fun to play
why this white is better here yeah Queen
deform was actually what I expected but
by now I saw that after Queen before I'm
a little bit struggling and then he
surprised me with the move Bishop takes
f6 um I thought I had thought about the
move but I thought that Queen diva is
just obviously the right one and I
didn't really think about this so much
because the bishop on b2 is the stronger
piece compared to f6 um yeah here
however I made a mistake and I saw that
night x h for Bishop d 89 fggf rook
cheeks is ok for black it quite
obviously is he can play that said c5
but I have Bishop d7 rook c8 it's not
that one of those pawns I guess they're
not promoting or anything black guys
okay yeah this is an equal position I
saw that but my problem was my my
misconception was that when i took with
the jeep on but you did I only reckoned
with Queen deform because Queen d4 was
what I had expected in the first place
and I just made this comparison let's
say I with fish appear bedroom and the
knight on f6 and he I don't have any
problems at all i can just take on c4 I
know Bishop takes and then b6 and they
have no problem at all i can get here
and the bishop missing on b2 is a huge
difference this pawn is also controlling
important square
so this is just very nice for me no
problem at all I'd rather actually
prefer black here man it's it's equal
but I would like to be black him my
problem was my other side was that he
doesn't have to go to deform he went to
h6 and this is once you see it you see
ok white the screen is a bit off side
but he has a very direct attacking idea
and this is h4 h5 Luke edge reroute g3
checkmate and when you start to try to
find defensive set up you will see it's
not so easy yeah here I spent some time
and try to figure out what to do against
this and it is very difficult it's
already a very difficult situation it is
not that black is lost but you have to
be very very precise to to find them a
good defense um it seems that what the
computer is suggesting with still a
slight rubber for black but it seems to
be ok computer wants to go Queen to e7
and move that I did not really consider
that much because this looks kind of
kind of ugly well this is ugly but I
don't have to take I have other moves in
comparison in as an alternative the
computer is actually suggesting rook d 8
which is kind of funny but it is strong
after the capture black even has Quincy
five this looks I know it looks utterly
ridiculous but it is working yeah this
is a strong counterplay idea check and
this is actually a problem now for white
how is white going to to defend now if
he goes 92 I can even take it yeah it
looks strange but this is all of a
sudden even winning now or better for
Blackett laser
can can try to analyze this is quite
funny of course I didn't see any of that
here in fact yeah it's not that right
it's lost year after this this you can
actually take here and after Queen c3
perpetual with his own Queen some some
lines like that those kind of super
sharp lines are probably still okay like
he can instead of course he can play age
form just according according to plan
and then I have ideas like route to da
time actually or taken now then luke t
aid which gives me an important
defensive resource here yeah something
like that actually gave scientists to
defend but it was very inconvenient
especially considering that I hadn't
really think really thought about Queen
age 60 I was only focused on
centralizing and correct the Queen
deform this is actually something that
happens to me often would be a bit much
but it happens to me I am am very much
strategically focused player and a very
often think mostly about moves that are
related to central control and so on
which is not a bad thing in general but
sometimes they're just concrete moves
that that address let's say king
position or something something very
very concrete and they are just stronger
than looking at some some kind of
following some some general principle
and here this happened yeah queen 86 is
just very very inconvenient to play
against i played 'if i've actually and i
think after that i'm losing it it's
really like that after if I've i don't
think i can i can save it I don't think
I can he played age for my idea with a
55 was that I control the age three
square so that age for Luke h3 it's not
easily possible but it's not mattering
we are talking about something very
concrete IAM h4 and yeah now i really
have no alternative h5 is the threat and
after 97 Queen takes f6 that's it I have
to play you for that's the only move and
now he went age five yeah and here I
have to play 95 there's nothing has
really no other move what what else this
is crashing through on age seven takes
takes takes here f6 and this position is
that I saw when I went five and well I
wasn't exactly enthusiastic here but I
thought that when I went when I will go
Queen d6 Bishop d7 rook c8 I might have
some counter play here against the Queen
side and he's not so quick with his
attack however what I didn't see um and
what happens in the game is how quickly
he can organize an attack against my
king with other means we would see how
it happened f6 this what happened he
played rook see one that sets a strong
move after Queen d5 to start with the
simple stuff I'm losing my queen so I
went Queen d6 having a look at this
however it's not that I can easily take
the pawn because of Rube c7 saw
something as it has to be taken into
account what I have to say is that from
here actually I'm also after age for
from 15 age for he's now playing
completely perfect moves I think if you
check it with with the computer the
computer absolutely approves of every
move so you played this very very nicely
he spent his share of time he didn't
have much time left at the end but it
didn't matter I was so busted at it that
the lower time did not matter at all he
played Bishop b2 this is stronger than
Bishop c4 for example am Bishop c4 is
it's not a bad move but Bishop e2 is
stronger it keeps the C file open and I
will never be able to take on d5 anyway
so Bishop c4 it doesn't make any sense
to protect the pawn yeah I played Bishop
d7
he canceled yeah and around TM I was
taking a longer time and tried to figure
out what to do cassoulet is a very
strong move by the way and I mean maybe
you say her what else but I was still
thinking that maybe he will do wants to
do something with the H far the rook but
there is no root lift ever going to
happen and this is stronger because of
the idea F form um I now became aware
how strong this idea is if I now play a
move it's difficult actually let's say
King edge am some kind of defensive move
he has this f4 idea and this is really
really problematic it it takes my my paw
information and something like that it's
very very annoying and never forget
white is already a porno p.m. I have
lost the pawn on d5 I will actually
never have the time to grab the a3 pawn
yeah it's it's really it's lost him it's
a loss pollution you can can really
there's no way around that I ultimately
decided to take the porn on a three just
like okay he either now kills me or I
have grabbed the pawn but he absolutely
he did kill me how it played it as
mentioned and there was all of our
perfect moves now he played d6 this is
very strong yeah d 6 it cuts the retreat
to e7 if I take on d6 he's got that yeah
something like that it's just winning or
alternatively the check and now this is
winning
checkmate remembered some this funny
funny attacking possibilities I cannot
take the pawn and he's got Luke c7
coming on Bishop c4 coming yeah I played
King edge aid and now Bishop g4 that's
the next the next strike that that's
hitting me Bishop g4 very strong ever
take it Luke c7 and i'm getting getting
checkmated here so very strong move and
it's with tempo yeah attacking this
Bishop if I play here it's over yeah I
played f5 and well us saw what was
coming but what can you do Luke c7 again
best move attacking this now the queen
is covering the pawn I went here and he
played Bishop f5 and after that I
resigned with a heavy labor the clear
conscience this is really probably it's
a force mate I didn't dare let the
computer calculate that to the end there
there should be a force made somehow so
there was a really brutal defeat in 25
moves I don't really lose like that so
often in this a quick fashion but yeah
that was very very nicely played on a
key moment was that I completely really
underestimated Queen to h6 and really my
sense of danger was was off in this some
in this situation I was and it was
mostly because I had considered this
Queen d4 move earlier with the bishop
and nights still on the board I was only
looking at that one and then he played
this and in all of the Sun hit me oh
wait this is kind of annoying and it's
really difficult to play I mean I
defended badly but we are already
talking about it really inconvenient
situation now um yeah not nice i'm
really know nice and ye five was some
probably am giving it away but
difficult and to be honest I mean I
plate didn't play a good game here that
that is clear but I don't really blame
myself too much in here because some he
really played it excellently I mean
after ye five this is sort sequence
after age 40 checked it with with the
comp it's it's perfect play it really is
I mean there's maybe one or two
situations where you can play wave like
two or three somewhat moves of equal
value yeah but it was very very nicely
played so um yeah nothing else to say he
just crushed me very very good game okay
this was the first ugly game and the
second game this is really ugly I mean
this is oops okay going to going to load
load the second one oops yeah okay
fortunately also not a very long game so
I don't have to suffer while free while
recording it playing black against
details tolima beats yours that's a top
junior player from Lithuania and he
scored it I am known in this event and
this final i am known so you get the
title shortly yeah so I lost against the
two guys who Scott know at least so I
did a good term yeah it was a good deed
let's say yeah people actually could use
the points that I had that I that I gave
to them if you want they they aren't
them yeah you know but when you lose it
should be for purpose auntie and both
were pretty a friendly guy so let's see
he went see for this is this plan he am
normally plays d4c for surprised me a
little but he hadn't played that for a
longer while and I didn't prepare much
for the game to be honest by now I was a
I mean I couldn't score anything in this
event without of any norm contention and
I was mostly am trying to enjoy the
asian let's say and I was sitting down
in play so I went c4b 6 this is not the
most solid opening ever but it is it is
ok actually um let's see he didn't
expect that I think he just played what
he what he does with efore here I went
Bishop before and I played Bishop d3
this might look a bit strange if you
have never seen it before but it is not
a bad idea the idea is that what white
is doing he's not playing the deep on
yet he quite often will play Bishop to
see two and later D for with the bishop
on C to securely protecting the e4 pawn
another idea this is actually very neat
if I play Knight is seven now which is
the traditional move there or let's say
the most most play move White has the
interesting idea knight to e to this is
quite quite nice it asks this Bishop ok
where are you going to go it's a bit
inconvenient this is an idea that i
actually had used myself when i played
more of one see form i was aware of the
idea and i wanted to avoid it so i
immediately captured on c3 which is yeah
i mean it is not super great that you
have to do that without being provoked
but it's not a big deal actually why it
takes and now um now I made them yeah
mistake is maybe a bit strong but maybe
you can call it that then um I was
actually playing the next move a bit too
quickly i played 97 and I really thought
that the move order here is not that
important actually but 97 is not it's
not so great what I should do is I
should actually play d6 and try to play
e5 him they are putting the pawns on
dark squares and maybe later try 97 and
l5 yeah but I should start to put the
pawn on e5 I think this is the better
better way to play a paid 97 castles and
now d 6 is better than castling i played
this too quickly simply i applied after
this and and then I thought next f5 this
was what I was thinking but I should
play with d65 the problem is he now has
a movie 5 this has only been played once
it said it's a rare rare move but in
fact um Black now has slight problems
really has the problem is that i cannot
play a normal move anymore or let's say
that's a bit bit wrong let's say up ND
six then white actually has the degree
gift yeah really check completely
killing black i mated or losing huge
chunks of material the bishop h7
business is serious so what is it that i
should do um I actually very quickly
decided on the move Knight g6 yeah just
putting it there putting pressure on you
five maybe sometimes I can even take
here and I can play a 5 later however
after I've played that and I played it
quickly I recognized when one more
opponent started to think pretty quickly
realized oh wait what exactly am I going
to do if you place 95 and when you look
at that NAT g5 you will see that the
move Queen age 5 this threat is very
very problematic what is black going to
do now yeah if I play age 60 he can take
here and black resigns yeah I'm just I'm
just losing this and well something like
this is a disaster
I cannot play age six but what am I
supposed to play Queen age five is going
to happen let's say I play the night
queen age five and why do we win this is
just just a disaster White has won a
pawn and has a fantastic attacking
position on top yeah 95 was absolutely
disastrous it totally did wins 95 just
wins the game it could have been one of
my quickest losses but you didn't do
that he played straight rookie wanna
surprisingly enough rookie one yeah I
really don't know it was a bad game four
from a bad move let's say 96 especially
playing that that quickly I should have
done something else it's not so nice
actually already because you you're
faced with this Bishop eighth seventh
fret probably I should play something
like age six and then go from there but
it's not a very convenient position this
earlier d65 was stronger ya na g6 he
could have killed me with 95 but he
played rupee one okay now I played d6 i
was already i had recognized by now that
not g 5 was very very strong and that
was like okay he didn't do that one and
i played d6 year they are going to
attack the center i hope and moving the
8th porn it was possible actually this
is not a terrible move but i wanted to
attack the center with g6 yeah and now
he played Bishop g5 and this is a very
sharp move let's say yeah it is some it
is controversial I saw that and they had
prepared the following sequence and the
it is I think okay when I'm playing now
but it is not really necessary I mean I
could have played Queen d7 and just play
this position but I went for Bishop f3
which is interesting hmm initiates a
forcing sequence and I still think that
this is okay the computer agrees
actually but it is some
justing so I'm giving up an exchange for
what ya f 97 this is important and
winning a tempo on the Queen and the
Queen really only has fo as a squared
went to f3 am sorry a three or four
white cannot really take he can but it's
not very attractive I'm taking him this
idea as well and I mean stuff like that
it's just very very inconvenient yeah
I'm going to get material back and yeah
not really not really nice I should
state that by the way the white player
he needed to win to to get near his IM
norm it wasn't a completely mended Tori
Winn well but almost um 97 yeah okay you
went Queen f3 this is a this is the the
better choice him okay I took and this
was planned Queen III and now I ever I
recognized and this is some time x
typical I recognize that my initial idea
is not what's not working I was
initially thinking that now night f4
would be good one f1 and then I can take
this was my idea when i played this
Bishop takes f 3 f five moves ago but
wyd of course has Queen g3 and I'm
losing a piece yeah simple
miscalculation I actually thought that
I'm okay even if I cannot win the c-4
porn it's not that it's the end of the
world but i was when i started the
sequence i thought i could do that the
night shift for move and when I
recognized that I was obviously not very
am NOT very thrilled but it is in fact
not a big deal the position is
completely okay for black I just have to
play it right um and what I probably
should do here is I played an age 6 by
the way what I probably should do is um
I should play other night f4 immediately
or I can also take it's not a big
problem I can do this and now player 5
you would see the difference to the game
yeah this
of endgame here is very very difficult
for white to make any substantial
progress the Knights on not only five is
very strong and his Bishop is actually
somewhat clumsy piece because it's not
never going to attack something here in
this position yeah black is very compact
and has most pawns on dark squares of
course it is a purely defensive
formation for black but some information
that is very very resilient and I would
be pretty confident that black will draw
this year in the long run but yeah it's
not very great or something and you can
just stay but it is a very solid of
course it's difficult to break down the
other idea is not f4 immediately Bishop
f1 and now i can try something like that
yeah attacking the Queen something like
that with those active Knights kind of
harassing him that also seems like a
decent idea one idea is also to to kind
of yeah perpetually attack the Queen for
example let's say rook do you wanna hear
hear yeah and I'm threatening g5 night
let h 52 to draw there are ideas here
but this is maybe the best one it's it's
difficult to say but I think I'm okay
it's not a not a huge issue this
position however I played the move h6
and this is a this is a misconception
simply um the thing is that um the good
thing about this move would actually
threaten something if you place I mean
okay this is just just nonsense but if
he plays a move like that I'm actually
check having the better position here
but it's not not going to happen the
problem is that after after age six the
problem is not that one I was
considering this this is actually very
okay for me because the pawn is very
useful in securing the night only five
but what is a problem he takes on g6
and after Queen takes which is what I
have to do b3 this position in
comparison to the other positions with
an exchange down is much worse because
he was able to trade his Bishop of this
sounds a bit strange why should white be
willing to trade off his Bishop problem
was in this position the bishop on d3 or
you can place it wherever you want on
the board it's not a very useful piece
it will never attack something my pawn
structure is very compact yet this kind
of paw information so the bishop is
fairly useless piece and here he managed
to trade it it is still a position that
shields them very resilient yeah my pawn
structure doesn't have any weaknesses
and his rooks are not not working very
well all together however and this is
really the worst part of it what I'm
doing now in the last in the next couple
of moves some is really bad it is just
really bad um and I really don't know
why what was the rationale here I really
don't know I played queen age 5 and
queen age form yeah this is kind of I
don't know placing the Queen on active
square and it is not really connected to
to any plan um when you look at this
from here I should really find some or
trying to find a setup that is that it's
tough to break down and what one might
be such a setup for example something
that comes to mind is if you let's say I
play something like this i play a five
and then I try let's say to bring the
Queen over here to see 6 or c5 on those
squares it would be very difficult for
him with the pressure on the sea pawn to
move the Queen side yeah if he plays f4
he's surrendering the e4 square
sometimes they're like 97 f 694 this
kind of thing this is a very tough to
break down set up white is better
of course because it's the only one who
can win Black is just holding I mean the
only way black and win is if wide
somehow makes mistakes and trying to
realize his advantage but generally
speaking this is just trying to hold it
but it would be pretty difficult to
break down if I would play a setup like
that um yeah it's kind of 5050 chances
you have fifty percent of wide win and
fifty percent of a draw if you give it
to a comp if you want the comp
evaluation 0.3 it's just it's not like
+1 or anything it's it's a difficult
position to to to win ok I played those
moves which well would be okay if I
would really go back let's say two da to
d7 to c6 but I really didn't have any
any plainer I should go to d8 now I went
to f6 and he went before yeah and now we
see he is coming with before and c5 and
this is not not easy at all to counter
he had an idea not a good idea but I had
an idea um I went 97 now a4 yeah I was
actually hoping that you would trade
Queens but he didn't he played a 4 and
yeah now I went night paj this phase of
the game is just terribly played I mean
I didn't have any any constructive idea
what to do and I mean okay admittedly i
was a bit frustrated about the whole
thing but yeah you know you play you
could have lost after move 9 and now
you're in this in this somewhat yeah
unattractive positioner and exchange
down but still I pretty plate I really
didn't play I didn't have any ideas of
whatever with those moves so it was just
like shuffling around while he plays
very young but with a clear purpose a4 I
went here yeah going for possibly 96 so
I make
intending to take and play 96 but you
can just remove the Queen from that and
now really what is my night doing yeah I
went here to stop a five from the moment
but she had Queenie form and it's very
inconvenient now where it's my night
going yeah no good squares you have no
good squares I went to e7 yeah note that
I'm just moving my pieces without any
plans was just terrible queen bee 7nts
enter now yeah now i can as a little
tactic but it's not mattering the
ultimately decisive factors that he's
got the acorn and the a pond will win
yeah if I let's say take here he has a
six yeah not taking yeah this is of
course a big mistake after this I will
draw this probably very easily but he
has after this is a six and the a pawn
will decide decide the issue so after a
five I have played Queen c6 looxcie one
Queen yet yeah if I go rook a eight
which looks attractive at first you can
just take him I can take on b6 also this
is also also win yeah this is check
check also winning very easily yeah
after this he took and I resigned yeah
so it I managed to lose a pretty
resilient position on the 15 if we go
back here this was moved 15 this is a
position really that if you lose it is
black you should lose on a new 60 or so
and not like in in 30 moves but I really
don't know i was playing this without
any any kind of plan or whatever it was
just like I was charting our moves
without any any idea really nothing else
that i can then i can say yeah I mean I
obviously wasn't in a great mood or
anything or something about the
hope the Donovan went but still I should
make some some kind of plan or idea when
I was looking at the game just today um
I didn't look at it after it was played
and not just a little bit it really
occurred to me how idiotic this was so
hit me know this this play it was like
completely without a plan yeah if when I
was looking at it today the the first
thing that came to our mind was this
this mansion setup yeah with maybe night
here and trying to bring the Queen over
this is really tough to break down I
mean I'm not confident that what we'll
do this easily and yeah this is what I
must do where you need to find in this
kind of situation this is a fortress
type of thing and you have to find a
decent setup and I really I remember
that I wasn't thinking clearly at this
moment everyone really looking for a
good setup and if you find a good one
like the 1i I just mentioned you will
have chances to hold this yeah it's a
it's very easily imaginable that if the
Queen sided there are some trades a
pawns and so on it can easily happen
that at the end there will be some end
game where white will have the exchange
for the palm but you will not be able to
break through because of blacks a very
solid structure he doesn't have a
weakness there's an open file so this
actually could have been an interesting
game when I if I have had to defend it
this was some some reasoning but the way
I played it was just a just a terrible
performance yeah a nice win for the
White play he was very very glad how
obviously scoring this this is point for
in some international master norm I
should have made it a little bit
difficult for him of course but um yeah
it really was a barrier those two final
games but I thought there was still some
interesting moments in them especially
the game against oh ma he did a very
fine attacking attacking job in that
game so I hope you enjoyed the coverage
of this tournament anyway it wasn't
really strong
chest from from my side but still
interesting i hope the next feature on
the channel will be the viewer games and
i'm going to probably release the first
one on what is this Thursday Wednesday
no this is out on wednesday right this
video so probably on thursday the next
couple of days there will be the first
analyze to viewer game so I'm glad to to
start this new series on this channel
thanks for watching this by